Ukraine says that Russian shelling has
completely knocked out electricity and
killed two people in Hassan
the southern Europe the southern city
has been the target of repeated Russian
attacks since it was recaptured by
Ukrainian forces last month across
Ukraine Russian strikes on the energy
Network have left millions of people
facing the harsh winter without heat or
power
heating water on an open fire
become routine for Allah her home in the
eastern city is without power and
running water
Russian troops are just five kilometers
away but she's determined to stay here
and endure
I wish I had some kind meat but there's
no meat it's cold but we still survive
the winter
all I want is peace here in the southern
city of Carson residents are also facing
a daily struggle
Russia continues to pound the city
recently liberated by Ukraine
with limited supplies waiting in Long
youth is now part of daily life all of
the pharmacies are closed this one here
in the city center is the only one open
International Aid is a Lifeline for some
this Center is providing food and relief
from the freezing temperatures
I'm inside what they call a resilience
Center outside is raining it's freezing
and it's dangerous
inside
thanks to the efforts of the government
and thanks to the efforts of so many
who've given so much support to the
people of Kasson
we're beginning to see lives starting
again
but such centers can't help all the
ukrainians currently in need it
for the latest on the situation in
Ukraine we are joined Now by our
correspondent Nick Connelly who is in
key for us hi there Nick can you tell us
more about these reports coming in about
the Russian attacks on Hassan
so just in the last couple of hours
we've had reports of two fatalities in
Herson one is believed to be a doctor
the other a local resident as far as we
understand this was right slap bang in
the middle of Harrison not far from the
government building that was also
attacked yesterday uh we understand that
this was a humanitarian Relief Center
and that that was where the hit was I
think this just kind of really brings
home the reality that there is nowhere
in Hassan right now that is safe from
these Russian attacks you've got the
Russian forces on the other Bank of the
new Pro River just a couple of
kilometers away and with their rocket
artillery with their standard artillery
they can basically hit everywhere in the
city and now especially now a couple
kind of a couple weeks in since the
Ukraine's came back it had seemed like
life was getting back to normal Services
were being restored uh Power had largely
been restored and that is now totally
gone just when we were there in the
first few days we happened to be passing
by some power infrastructure and saw the
shells coming in so it's really a kind
of uh pretty endless task trying to
rebuild with infrastructure knowing the
Russians can see what's going on with
their drones and as soon as anything is
kind of nearing completion they can just
destroy it and set everything back to
square one so that is the situation that
kept us on right now and I think lots of
people who maybe had been thinking about
returning to caterson now that things
were seemingly normalizing are going to
think twice about that Nick I want to
ask you two about some allegations that
we're hearing uh by Ukrainian officials
that Russian soldiers have tortured
Ukrainian miners in the in the Hassan
region has that been confirmed
so for now we've heard from Ukraine's
Ombudsman for human rights that there
are reports of several teenagers having
been kept in kind of the sellers in the
place of detention where the Russians we
know also held adults for days at a time
often without water we met when we were
Carson a man in his late teens who had
been kept there for weeks on end his
family knew nothing about where he was
he was tortured with electrical shocks
he was beaten up he was kept and
threatened with execution so there
definitely is a sense they're going to
be a lot more stories coming out of
Carson as the kind of Investigations
continue and there's very little to
suggest that somehow the Russians behave
better in Afghanistan towards civilians
than they did in other parts of Ukraine
they've been occupied so lots of work
happened there and I think I've actually
more depressing and you know sad stories
to come out of her son before you know
investigators get to end of this Nick
thank you so much for that that's DW's
Nick Conley and Keith
now with the backdrop of Russia's
continued aggression in Ukraine the
European Parliament has called the
Soviet Union's policy that starved
millions of ukrainians to death a
genocide it's approved a resolution that
recognizes the early 1930s a lot of more
famine as a quote deliberate policy of
the Soviet regime as genocide against
the Ukrainian people
and joining us now from Strasbourg to
talk talk more about that vote is DW
correspondent Barbara hi there Barbara
can you tell us what this means for
Ukraine the fact that the EU has now
officially declared the whole lot of
more a genocide
it is of course Anya a political act it
is an act that is supposed to Anchor the
holodimore in the history books because
this was a largely unexplored and partly
forgotten uh part of the Ukrainian
history and of the genocides of the 20th
century and only in recent years
historians have come and explored what
happened then and have said this is an
atrocity this is something that the
Russia's dictator uh Stalin sort of
initiated deliberately in order to break
the spirit of ukrainians one aspect was
the collectivization of farms and so
what happened was that his his
functionaries took away all grain and
all livestock from Ukrainian farmers and
the figures how many people died through
that they vary between like three
million and the five or seven million
nobody really knows but whole stretches
of the countryside were completely
depopulated because people were starving
to death and the other aspect was of
course that starting already then wanted
to break the political resistance and
the political Spirit and the sense of
national identity of ukrainians so this
is what's behind this and it the the
resolution the European Parliament
accepted today means that this is now
increasingly going down as effect in
international history books whereas so
far it has been just a side aspect
Barbara thank you so much that's DW
correspondent Barbara Visa in Strasbourg
now the war in Ukraine is dominating the
agenda in Brussels where EU leaders are
gathering in an attempt to put out
multiple fires on Europe's doorstep
negotiations are expected to go well
into the night as the conflict is
testing the resolve and unity of the 27
member states
joining the meeting via video link is
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
but despite near unanimous support for
Kiev the spillover effects of the war
have deepened divisions on issues from
additional sanctions on Russia to how to
tackle record inflation and a growing
energy crisis
and we're joined Now by our
correspondent in Brussels Bentley we're
now 10 months into the Ukraine war and
EU solidarity has been tested over the
response to Russia and energy policies
tell us how strong is the unity between
the EU member states right now
well in principle all 27 leaders he
agree and we confirmed their commitment
to for aid for Ukraine also in the long
term when it comes to humanitarian Aid
to reconstruction also to the delivery
of weapons and also budget aid for the
Ukrainian state but the devil is in the
details here because the leader should
agree on a new eight package of 18
billion euros for next year as a budget
aid for Ukraine to enable the state to
pay pensions and to pay salaries but in
the beginning of the week Hungary hold
up the process and now Poland is
blackmailing the rest of the EU Poland
does not want to agree unless Poland
gets something on its own interest they
want access to the corona Recovery Fund
which is blocked because Poland has some
issue with with the rule of law and so a
lot of for bargaining and bickering is
going on here right now behind a closed
doors and also there's no agreement on
the ninth sanctions packets that should
hit Russia their Hungary is also holding
up the process so there's a lot to talk
about maybe until tomorrow morning and
also the issue of a gas price cap for
wholesale gas in Europe is not resolved
there are two camps that are saying we
want that to as a relief our citizens
and the other Camp is saying no you will
endanger gas supply so a lot to talk
about and nothing is actually resolved
right now